I love going to see a movie when you see
lots of London in it it's just I know
just it's kind of you know could write
oh I've been there
oh yeah I know that but I heard you
talking about how there were specific
problems doing some of the big exterior
things in London with you he was free I
mean it's very hard to lock off London
you can't close many roads and I was
doing a scene one day and and I they
called cut I was up why that was I was
going when he won I look behind me and
there's a bus goes past with my face on
it I was doing movie at the Tyco movies
coming out called Pompeii and I was in
this gladiator outfit with like kind of
bare chested so like every day it was
funny for the first two time my face
they called cart and I get up there and
there I am again ten foot Meredith I
hate when that happens
all you want is a dinkle but you envy is
a Shuang a sings love it you